Speaker 1: I hate to go back to our story
of projection, but I sort of have to.
One of the big stories that Republicans have been
telling for a long time now is Democrats are going
to commit fraud when it comes to the election.
Democrats are going to send people out to vote
twice. Democrats are going to send out people
to vote in the names of those who have died.
They're going to do all these different things.
And of course, none of it happened. But we
now have yet another example of a Republican
who did just that. And it's a Trump staffer,
a former Trump staffer who is running for the
New Hampshire House voted in two states in 2016.
We're going to go through it, but then it's also
an important opportunity to clarify things that
are actually against the law versus things that
are really no big deal that Republicans still
say are against the law. Associated Press reports
Trump aides seeking New Hampshire House seat
voted in two states in 2016. A former Trump
administration official now running for Congress
in New Hampshire voted twice during the 2016
primary election season, potentially potentially
violating federal voting law. And, of course,
leaving him at odds with the Republican Party's
focus on so-called election integrity. We're
talking about matt mowers or Mowers, a leading
Republican primary candidate who wants to upset,
unseat, rather Democratic Rep. Chris Pappas.
Matt Mowers cast an absentee ballot in
New Hampshire's 2016 presidential primary,
according to voting records. At the time,
he was the director of former New Jersey
Gov. Chris Christie's presidential campaign. Four
months later, Chris Christie was gone, and Mowers
cast another ballot in the New Jersey
Republican presidential primary, using
his parent's address to reregister in his home
state. Is this against the law? It appears to be.
Legal experts say his actions could violate a
federal law that prohibits more voting more than
once in any general, special or primary election.
That includes casting a ballot in separate
jurisdictions. So there are two or three
different stories here. First of all,
when Republicans go on and on about voter fraud,
they want to make it seem like they're accusing
the other side. They seem to have been
describing their own actions. It's almost
like these Republican allegations end up being
confessions. Oh no, you can't vote for Hillary
because she won't be trustworthy with classified
information, and she had a private email server.
We know how that turned out. And it's
the exact same thing here. But what I
really want to focus in on because listen, they
we keep catching these Republicans doing this
stuff. It's almost not even news that they keep
getting caught doing this stuff. Mark Meadows
voting registered in two states. All these
different things. Important reminder, just because
the right says something is illegal doesn't
mean it is, and let me give you some examples.
Being registered in two different states is not
against the law as long as you don't vote in two
different states. What malware's did appears to
be illegal, but it is not uncommon that people
live in one state and are registered there. And
then after the primary and before the general,
they move to a different state. And then they
register there and they legally vote as long
as you didn't vote in both states, just being
registered in two places is not against the law
and it, but we have to remember that. Secondly,
they say, well, dead people voted. Tons of dead
people voted. There's no evidence of that.
But what sometimes happens is somebody was
alive. You vote by mail absentee and then you
die before the date of the general election.
That's not against the law. You haven't
done anything wrong. You were alive when
you voted. It becomes a clerical issue.
Another example people voted twice.
Oftentimes, Republicans will find that
someone was registered in two places
and they will say this person voted twice. As
long as you didn't actually vote twice, you're not
doing anything wrong. It's a clerical issue that
the old place where you lived hasn't registered
you. It's important to remember the mass scale
stuff they claim is happening isn't happening,
but a lot of the things that happen anecdotally
are not actually against the law. Do they actually
care that people understand that? Of course not.
Of course not. Make sure you are following us on
Instagram at David Pakman show we'll take a quick
break and be back after this with much, much more